j'ai une famille ouvrière on n'avait pas
forcément beaucoup de moyens on
travaillait pour prendre de l'argent de
poche et ben voila j'ai fait mon argent
à moi tout seul en autonomie totale
jamais été maquée rien à quoi bon se
retrouvent au bois de boulogne c'est
tout seul là bas en fait je suis arrivé
de la rochelle ouais mari et j'ai fait
des petits boulots ventes de
lithographie en porte à porte c'est
encore moins se lâcher les chiens
recevoir avec le fusil à on n'est pas
payé fait toute la semaine on vous dit
on veut payer la fin la semaine et puis
barre d'accord la boîte a disparu quand
même le tapin brunn voulait n'ayez pas
peur vous êtes tout seul la nuit comme
ça en fait on a peur de quoi si on va là
avec la peur au ventre on fait rien et
ça fait quand même donc travail homogène
26 ans 26 ans on va donner tous les
soirs bain beaucoup moins en ce moment
parce que avec tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment il ya des agressions ah bah
voilà non mais pas forcément de deux
filles envers les clients ça n'a rien à
voir mais beaucoup de groupes de 5 10
personnes en bois qui agressent les
finir par les sacs à main par les
cheveux les viols donc vous avez vous
dit rien il faut dire il ya du violon et
pourtant il n'est pas parce qu'on n'est
pas question de lui c'est pas parce
qu'on est une prostituée oui vous savez
pourquoi parce que beaucoup sont en
situation irrégulière et ont peur qu'on
allant commissaire a porté plainte chez
l'immigration que les roms c'est ça ou
je veux dire par là qu'il ya de la
police et le soir dans le bois de
boulogne la maman de nuit du 16e 6 alors
moi je trouve dans la rue route de la
porte dauphine à la porte des sablons ça
fait deux ans et demi clé dans le noir
y'a pas un lampadaire de lui mais je
vous parle les policiers je vous parle
pas d'eux mais les policiers on les voit
pas si les policiers passent en eux les
vous falloir pas au civil par don bruno
juste alors comment ça se passe une
journée au bois de boulogne pour ou
juste pour après vous avez une partie
s'est levée à faire est de votre dernier
sa durée commence à se faire donc c'est
quoi vous en verrez ils vont semer en
tenue parce qu'on arrive on prend les
transports c'est fini l'époque du taxi
on arrivait à eux des princesses déjà
maquillé ben non on prend les transports
en commun comme tout le monde on chausse
ses talons son mini jupe en se préparant
se conditionne et on commence
humblement sa jambe à d et jusqu à
gambader des fois jusque dans les métros
et quand on n'a pas fait de l'argent
qu'on n'a pas décollé ben on va jusqu'au
premier métro le matin ah ouais et des
fois pour rien faire on ne rien faire
généralement vous avez déjà été agressé
j'ai été agressé plusieurs forts coups
de couteau coups de cutter au visage
non on est agressé on se tapait dessus
insulté répondu j'avais pensé arrêter
faire autre chose que vous êtes
maintenant pourquoi qui vont engager
quelqu'un qui est transgenre ça me
cantonne à un certain cran une certaine
quantité ou catégories de d'emplois je
vais pas travailler dans la nuit j'ai
trop fait la fête la nuit je sais les
dérives j'ai pas envie de ça voici je
veux travailler c'est parce que vous
vous posez
j'aime moi la prostitution j'ai jamais
fait sa force et vous dites j'aime ce
que je fais bien sûr voilà je donne du
plaisir je peux prendre du plaisir faut
pas croire qu'une prostituée prend pas
son pied un c'est faux ou à l'épaule
mais non non on peut prendre son pied on
peut prendre son plaisir mais moi j'aime
bien combien arrive qu'il est fatigué de
sa semaine de boulot qu'il a galéré
qu'il arrête la subit et bien qu'ils
repartent avec le sourire oui elle ne
serait ce que ça je me dis je fais mon
travail j'ai bien accompli ma tâche et
j'étais rémunéré en échange bien bravo
merci alors ça fait des années donc vous
êtes au boulot nous on connaissait tous
les secrets il y avait déjà croisée des
sons bien sûr fait les deux noms à ce
que vous avez déjà parce que on va
parler de café à ce que vous avez déjà
produit des personnes connues mais vous
avant
politiques acteurs chanteurs wi ex de
tf1 également
[Rires]
ses films sont passés sur tf1 oui
d'accord annoncé au nom mais on va pas
en parler non mais y en a eu beaucoup il
ya beaucoup et puis il y en a qu'on ait
oublié le maintenant mais qui était
connu à l'époque et plus qui reviennent
maintenant
on a des casseroles on a des dossiers
ils ont des casseroles au cul est coincé
on le sait mais on ne peut pas dire sont
dit on perd on perd toute crédibilité si
vous voyez je suis devant les caméras
n'ont plus eu une [ __ ] l'emprunt c'est
un client a balance pas du direct
une règle des législations c'est comme
ça c'est pas si la question que vous
pose c'est parce que c'est vrai qu'à dix
d'entre eux connu on dit il faut pas
besoin de ça pour quoi ils viennent et
pourquoi ils n'auraient pas besoin de ça
no mi ser qui pouvaient ils ont ils ont
énormément de succès et bébé vous croyez
que le succès n'est pas du tout certain
ils n'ont pas envie de s'afficher ici je
vais dans le boisé discret je fais ma
petite affaire je fais ma vie danger je
me casse ah oui bien sûr égaux et avec
la plus belle accrue du monde elisabeth
hurley et pourtant il a été pris
si vous saviez le nombre de jeunes qui
se marie très jeunes qui sont en couple
qui ont des enfants qui sont heureux en
comble et puis bah un moment elle estime
avoir fait son devoir conjugal la ligne
migraine à chaque fois qu'il a envie
parce que s'il est bien il va pas se
coller sur l'oreille ce que c'est vrai
qu'elle n'est pas paradis qui viennent
parfois ici de surprendre des célébrités
alors ça j'ai jamais eu ça c'est vrai
par contre j'ai des flics qui sont
venues des caméras infrarouges fois
parce qu'il met avec notre accord parce
qu'il venait pour pisser
et et on les en remercie parce que vous
faut dire ce qu'est la police faisait
quand même bien son travail voilà encore
un serbe avec 75 de bonnes mais pas dans
les années 90 il ya eu des dérives alors
on va revenir sur cette affaire de ce
footballeur agressé au bois de boulogne
on a eu la version bruno pomart donc
apparemment ils auraient été dans sa
voiture quelqu'un se serait introduit
dans sa voiture une prostituée elle lui
aurait dérobé son portefeuille ainsi que
son téléphone et il aurait négocié 200
euros pour pouvoir repartir
et voilà et récupérer ses affaires donc
il n'a pas porté plainte
cissé il a porté plainte ou pas après a
commencé après coup d'accord quel est
votre vous je sais que vous connaissez
toutes les histoires là bas ça monte à
quelle est votre version je vendais des
croix se tiendra du tout
voilà
moi je bosse toute l'émission ah oui
alors oui généralement pas du tout c'est
quoi ta version doit pas du tout
justement comme disait monsieur
les voitures de ce modèle là de se
classent la fermeture centralisée et
automatique d'accord vous mettez le
contact c'est fou non c'est pas vrai
parce qu'ils vont mettre un petit truc
parfois
on vous jure que j'aimerais même dans
les boîtes
mails extrêmement l'a bien dit que
c'était un feu non mais ça peut arriver
part ça il faut configurer fermeture des
portes je ne l'avais pas confie t il a
bien dit que c'était arrêté à un feu
situé à travailler à proximité d'un feu
déjà d'une pourquoi parce que c'est
parce que ça peut provoquer des
accidents ou des carambolages là
d'accord oui donc ça faut le savoir je
comprends oui il faut le savoir oui car
voilà gens tous les sens du terme à sa
saison c'est le met pas sur l'ondé le
feu des croisements c'est le bon
on essaie de se mettre en retrait ou au
moins à 20 mètres d'accord les gens
aient le temps de s'arrêter rêvait déjà
durci s'arrêter au feu on va en pleine
nuit il n'y a pas dix voitures devant
lui c'est faux d'accord donc moi je vous
dis franchement c'est quoi l'intérêt sur
le c'est pas possible il a négocié
peut-être qu'une passe avec la fille il
a fait le kéké la 12e' ouais je suis
footballeur je gagne des sous je suis
pété de thunes il lui a sorti un billet
de 50 balles mais il a dû ouvrir
portefeuille et est arrivé ce qui devait
arriver je pense mais ça je veux pas
incriminer qui que ce soit parce que
c'est humain on travaille pas beaucoup
c'est galère en ce moment mais quand
même rim je vois d'ici le braquer c'est
ça d'ici a le bras cassé par le bras en
bras qu'avec une arme on braque accès
pour sa sagesse une occasion quand même
c'est pas prouvé que ce qu'elle est et
quel tard mais parce que madame sait
combien la passe c'est 20 à 30 euros la
peep la mort
merci bernard
gentil mais j'ai appris sur ton moi j'ai
franchement du mal à croire qu'une star
du psg comme ça qui est une star
mondiale derrière suivie par 4 millions
de personnes sur les réseaux prennent le
risque aujourd'hui je dis pas il ya 20
ans quand il est moins réseaux sociaux
sûr d'aller au bois de boulogne ça va
bien sûr avoir une relation sexuelle on
va pas se mentir je dis pas que c'est
son cas il ya plein de footballeurs qui
ont aujourd'hui des relations avec des
femmes il existe d'autres moyens pour le
faire et voilà j'ai du mal à croire
qu'il ait pris ce risque là mois la
version que j'ai eu c'est qu'ils
habitent effectivement à
neuilly-sur-seine qu'il était au parc
des princes entre chez lui et le parc
des princes et le bois de boulogne qu'il
est passé qui se tenait un peu de
manière ostentatoire cinquième essai
montre son portefeuille de ses terres
dans sa voiture et que cette femme est
rentrée dans sa voiture et lui c'est
quelqu'un de très gentil on le voit dans
les interviews etc voilà il a voulu
l'aider et il a été contraint lui donner
de l'argent la vraie question que tout
le monde se pose ce soir c'est samantha
est ce que ça vous fait plaisir de
retrouver votre fils
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a 30 ans
et ça fait plaisir de retrouver d'autres
je viens d'avoir
les chéris juste cette affaire elle est
complètement folle bruno pomart ça est
ce que c'est ça ça arrive souvent ce
genre de chose ou pas mais c'est
fréquent de manière à ces problématiques
dans la boîte boulonné c'est très très
fréquent mais pas que d'un goût douteux
tous les faits de droits communs comme
on disait dans paris et entre non
c'était mais ce qu'est ce qui est
surprenant encore une fois c'est que
comme tu dis il est super gentil mais en
fait moi ça ne viendrait pas à l'idée de
passer dans le bois de boulogne avec
massmart et même si je suis gentille que
j'étais une star vraiment peur de dire
que quelqu'un vient de perdre je la fais
rentrer dans ma bagnole c'est un choix
je n'aurais pas fait ça tu es une smart
la mienne
va travailler votre version s'appelle ma
version c'est qu'il s'arrêtait pour
consommer d'accord pour consommer il
s'est arrêté parce que de déverrouiller
une porte comme ça c'est soit on a peur
on n'est pas tirée par la personne ne
voit pas l'intérêt dans le bois le bois
qui est qui et qui kéké sombre on
s'aventure pas à monter un mec seul
peut-être en écho aux tournées on aimait
les sportifs mais on s'arrête pas comme
ça qu'une voiture hors de prix surtout
il s'est levé le montrent il avait de
losail sur lui un bon téléphone quelle
idée mais quelle idée donc l idée
franchement et je ne crois pas du tout à
ce que la fille est ouvert la porte
d'elle-même parce que je vous dis les
véhicules maintenant la technologie de
maintenant ça se verrouille
automatiquement
alors je n'y crois pas tout ce week-end
sans préjugés c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelque chose de bizarre c'était aller
de la reine marguerite s'est passé
exactement
non mais oui mais quand on tournait
année la reine marguerite duras son
arbre là bas pour effrayer g à cette
heure-là le club les brief c'est une
star internationale il a joué à
manchester united il joue au psg la cie
des cinq ans le club leur dis faites
attention il ya des endroits où on va
pas donc c'est vrai que cette affaire
elle est bizarre c'est c'est ce serait
hasard incroyable qu'à cet endroit là où
y'a pas il n'y a pas d'autres agressions
on n'a pas relevé récemment de plein
d'autres personnes en plus c'est vrai
que ça paraît quand même je ne préjuge
de rien ça paraît quand même hallucinant
soit simplement un hasard qu'un joueur
du psg à cet endroit la soie entre
guillemets agressé voilà ça paraît
surréaliste honnêtement ouais mais le
problème c'est qu'il est marié marié la
désenclaver la rue bories non mais c'est
sur le problème oui le problème boyer
agiront comme le dit gilles sont ils
sont tous briefé moi c'est pour ça que
de la sécurité de l'ensemble des joueurs
ils sont briefés sur toutes ces choses
là évidemment mais pourquoi sa fuite et
comment sa fuite parce qu'en fait c'est
parce macias qui porte plainte à sa
fuite sa fuite pas apparemment ça fait
même même j'ai même de la police lien il
ya toujours des informations qui fusent
de partout les sionistes qui préviennent
la prêtre qui font les wii a toujours
bébé sur ça a toujours existé musée
batha c'est à dire ici mais s'est fait
prendre les deux il a donné les 200
balles qu'il a su en fait c'est à dire
qu'il a su commencent à fuiter parce que
si là il aurait pas porter plainte s'ils
savaient pas futé ouais c'est ça que
l'argument sa fuite et c'est pas là
alors on a dansé lui qui a décidé de
porter plainte oui mais c'est parce que
c'est un pays dont il a fait un
signalement à la police mike pour pour
se dé se dédouaner je ne sais pas
avait dit tout à l'heure il assure que
j'ai seulement comme il avait vu que ça
commence à percer will a porté plainte
un prix alors après sa percée à oran qui
portent plainte signalement est porté
plainte parce qu'on peut faire le
signalement mais pas nécessairement
porter plainte - tafer a pris d'accord
juste vous c'est déjà arrivé ce genre
d'affaires ou pas du tout que je vole
non non mais non pas vous mais
j'ai réclamé ça dans votre fils
[Rires]
c'est pas bien est-ce qui s qui essaie
d'y arriver ce genre de cas où une jeune
femme voilà se sont introduits dans une
voiture volée
et n'importe quoi il faut coller aux pas
dire que ça n'est jamais arrivé se
serait donc ciblé mais mais il faut pas
faire passer des pubs pour des
malhonnêtes quoi que ce soit il peut y
avoir un moment de discorde ou de
troubles à l'appui la personne part en
live et part en vrille mais c'est
exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel c'est
rarissime donc moi je dis franchement
j'avais déjà eu des relations sont cités
avec des grands sportives ou d'échouer
oui relation tarifée oui oui oui oui les
pleins visiblement oui non c'est vrai
qu'on avait des genres des directives
politiques
ah
ouais chanteur oui oui oui homme de
médias vous vous reconnaissez les gens
ici
non mais non personne non même nom
[Rires]
ouais quand même sans discussion bien
même je vous demande quoi vous gagnez
par mois en moyenne deux par rapport à
avant madame avons combien à la belle
époque valait pas pouvait se faire entre
150 200 euros par jour d'accord en n'y
allant pas tous les jours bien sûr
l'accord mais saad a été divisé par cinq
par cinq voire six voire depuis la loi
de pénalisation des clients on a on est
en galère lac en souffrent on souffle
mais vraiment en souffre et beaucoup de
filles se retrouvent à la rue ou à
partager un studio à 3 pour pour ceux se
regrouper pour pellouailles et pour
bouffer pour voilà et galère certaines
sont dans des états catastrophique
niveau santé la saison pas le temps
elles font des nuits complètes puis
elles n'ont pas le temps de prendre soin
d'elle voilà et on a vu des gens à la
rue où vous trouverez tout seuls n'y a
personne qui vous êtes seul comme ça
vous arrive est notre seul monsieur
toujours tout seul jour où américain
cran d'arrêt lacrymogènes massage suis
prête ah ouais si ça
apparaît à côté ou quatre doigts ou qu'à
une voiture faut toujours prévoir
on sait jamais vous savez dans le bois
c'est dans une rue qui n'est pas
éclairée ouais il ya un bruit derrière
vous n'avez pas le temps de vous
retourner on se passait faut toujours
être prêt pour nous attaquer il faut pas
croire mais vous ce soir vous travaillez
non non ce soir non on voit ça un petit
peu avec votre fils des retrouvailles
sous
préfet vous préfériez pas la réouverture
des maisons closes mais si on était
considérés déclaré reconnu et que les
cotisations conversos reese par exemple
et 20 % sur chaque client
après on touche une retraite je veux
bien mais avant de lancer les maisons
closes penser déjà aux retombées
derrière parce que quand ils ont fait la
loi ps s'en déclarent ils ont dit c'est
pour vous protéger des filles ouais y'a
pas eu d'accès au logement social n'y a
pas eu de de parachute on va dire ou de
2,2 de matelas pour amortir la chute
on s'est retrouvé dans la merde dans la
merde dans un hôtel je fais 60 euros par
nuit je devais une semaine d'hôtel j'ai
dû partir mais je me suis sauvée on fait
comment vous n'êtes plus verbaliser
maintenant d'autres se montrent non
moi j'ai connu la fin de cette époque là
mais heureuse maintenant alors vous avez
des grandes stars est ce qu'un jour il
ya une personne voilà qui vous êtes de
mal faire genre un cachet incroyable
ouais c'est vrai jean roy époque des
saoudiens de 1500 euros la soirée non ah
ouais et je les ai connus à l'époque
défense et 25000 francs la soie ouais on
les voyait passer deux trois mois d'été
son pari après on les voyait pas pendant
neuf mois